bonjour et bienvenue dans le 78 de l'été
ce magazine sera consacré à l'histoire
et au patrimoine je vous invite à
traverser les couloirs du temps à la
découverte de quelques lieux parfois
méconnus qui font la richesse du
patrimoine ancien de notre département
pour débuter notre voyage direction
portmli où situe derrière moi un château
qui ne serait-ce que par son nom évoque
un univers fascinant le château de Monte
Cristo sur les hauteurs de Port Marly
niché au cœur d'un théâtre de verdure se
dessine le paradis terrestre d'Alexandre
Duma le château de Monte Cristo
l'écrivain au sommet de sa gloire en
1844 après le succès des trois
mousquetaires et du Comte de Monte
Cristo cherche à quitter Paris son rêve
faire construire une maison de campagne
sur les bords de seène séduit par la
commune de portmarly il choisit
l'architecte hippoly Duran et fit
construire en 1846 un château de style
Renaissance alexand Duma n'avait pas
donné de nom à sa maison et un jour une
actrice qui vient le voir se déplace de
Paris elle prend le train elle arrive au
PEC au PEC elle demande à un cocher de
l' menener chez Duma et le cocher ne
sait pas du tout de qui il s'agit donc
qu' elle est obligé d'expliquer elle dit
mais enfin si Duma vous savez bien le
compte de Monte Cristo les trois
mousquetaires et elle a à peine fini sa
phrase que le le cocher dit mais si vous
m'aviez dit que vous vouliez aller dans
la maison du compte de Monte Cristo je
vous y aurais emmené tout de suite donc
elle raconte cette anecdote à Alexandre
Duma il trouve ça très drôle et du coup
il se dit bah ma maison je vais
l'appeler le château de Monte Cristo
sculpté de toutes parts les façades du
château sont ornés de portraits
d'écrivain qui lui sont chers d'animaux
étranges et de sa devise personnelle
j'aime qui
m'aime parmi les 11 pièces du château se
trouve au premier étage un authentique
salon moresque dont les murs présentent
un décor de sculpture et d'arabesque
rapporté au cours de l'un de ses voyages
l'écrivain a imaginé sa maison comme il
vivait avec des mesures et
extravagance face à cette demeure un
Castelle néogothique appelé par Duma le
château d'If lui servira de cabinet de
travail l'architecture particul de cet
édifice souligne à nouveau tout
l'imaginaire de Duma classé aujourd'hui
monument historique le château et son
parc sont à visiter pour découvrir tout
l'univers du célèbre écrivain à travers
une collection de gravure peinture et
reproduction des expositions temporaire
d'art contemporain et des animations
tout au long de l'année accompagne
également les
visiteurs pour continuer notre
découverte du patrimoine ancien des
ivelines je vous propose un détour par
le domaine national de Port Royal des
champs à
maniléamo au confin de la commune de
maniléamo sur les pentes de la vallée de
Chevreuse se trouve un vaste domaine
forestier d'une trentaine d'hectares le
domaine national de Port Royal des
champs l'histoire de ce lieu commence au
13e siècle par la construction d'une
abbaye cistercienne de femmes qu'elles
occuperont près de 400
ans les religieuses quittent l'abaye et
s'installent à Paris tandis que les
solitaires ces hommes du monde qui ont
choisi de vivre une vie retirée de
l'agitation occupe le monastère puis les
granges de la partie agricole du domaine
cet abéaye de Port Royal est devenue une
abaye importante connue illustre et
parfois détestée à l'époque de Louis XIV
parce que dans cette abaye se regroupe
aux portes de cette abaye se regroupe un
certain nombre d'hommes de théologiens
de philosophes d'écrivains qui ont
laissé un certain nombre de textes et
d'écrit qui ce sont des textes
théologiques ce sont des textes
philosophiques ou ce sont des textes
pédagogiques euh ces écrivains eux ont
une vision de la société qui n'est pas
forcément celle du roi c'est ce qui fait
la célébrité de Port Royal pendant le
règne de Louis XIV et c'est parce que
ces ces écrivains se sont dressés contre
le roi que le roi a souhaité faire
disparaître l'abaye il a souhaité
qu'elle soit détruite c'est sans doute
parce que il a voulu la détruire
qu'aujourd'hui le souvenir de cette Abay
reste encore extrêmement fort pour nous
qui habitons saint-quanttin en iveline
pour les Français et au-delà pour
beaucoup de nos concitoyens européens
pour quiiport Royal reste un endroit
très très important de ce haut lieu de
la pensée ganéniste dont Jean Racine fut
l'élève le plus célèbre reste à visiter
les ruines de l'abaye et le
musée l'occasion au terme d'une
promenade dans le parc d'entrer dans ce
musée qui conserve une riche collection
de gravur livres anciens portraits et
ouvrages souvenir des personnalités
écrivains et philosophes qui ont vécu
ici il y a quelques siècles le Musée
national de Port Royal des champs a
inauguré en mai dernier après un vaste
chantier de restauration un salon datant
du 19e siècle nous avions rencontré les
deux restauratrices en charge du projet
elles se sont rencontrées voilà 20 ans
dans un atelier de peinture de
techniques anciennes le chantier de
restauration d'un salon du 19e siècle du
Musée national de Port Royal des champs
à Manil les hameau est l'occasion pour
Sophie et iliette d'aller leur talent
pour la première fois et de mê les
restauration et approche d'un chantier
traditionnel ce sont des chantiers qui à
l'époque étaient réalisés par des
peintres décor
donc j'ai la
l'approche pratique du de de chantier
finalement donc là la restauration est
un petit peu particulière dans la mesure
où on a une un côté restauration toute
une partie restauration qui est quand
même qui concerne plus de la moitié du
du salon et une partie restitution
puisque l'on a découvert que ce salon
avait
été restitué déjà au 19e siècle le
chantier a débuté par la réintégration
picturale en octobre 2012 mais les
premières peintures ont été découvertes
et nettoyées il y a plus de 3 ans tels
deux archéologues Sophie et ielliet ont
découvert leurs différentes couches
successives en remontant dans le temps
jusqu'à découvrir la teinte originale du
18e siècle patiné presque bronze à cause
de l'oxydation et divers traitements aux
huiles et aux CIR redécouvrir la couleur
originale ne fut pas chose aisée les
peintures de dessus de porte ont
largement renseigné nos deux expertes là
je suis en train d'appliquer une trè
couche c'est la couche de peinture verte
fraîche à la colle de peau qui a
été réaliser avec des pigments et de la
colle de
peau voilà pour réintégrer c'est-à-dire
pour redonner l'illusion
de de l'ensemble alors bien entendu on
le débord de pas sur la peinture
originale que l'on a
conservé les tableaux entièrement
remarouflés sur un nid d'abeille
conservve leur plastique de protection
pour éviter les coulures le salon est
l'un des derniers décors anciens du
musée qui n'avait pas encore été
restauré l'opération devrait s'achever
au printemps le salon accueillera les
premiers visiteurs pour la Nuit des
musées en mai 2013 d'ici là seule plume
peut en
profiter le patrimoine ancien se situe
parfois au cœur des villes et même des
villes nouvelles je me trouve devant
l'église saint-victore à guillancour un
édifice façonné au fil de l'histoire
pour nous en parler nous allons
retrouver l'UR Vallette qui est
animatrice du patrimoine et de
l'architecture pour le musée de la
ville lurvallette bonjour bonjour
pouvez-vous nous dire de quand date
cette église oui l'église de guencour S
construite sur plusieurs siècle nous
avons des éléments à l'ouest au niveau
du clocher à la base qui date du 12e
siècle il y a aussi des éléments du 13e
siècle puis viennent les quatre
premières travées de la nef qui seraiit
vraisemblblement constru au 14e siècle
ensuite on sait avec certitude que le
cœur est lui complètement reconstruit au
16e siècle ensuite l'Église a connu
différentes périodes de travaux nousous
avons plusieurs restauration au 19e
siècle et puis au 20e siècle elle est
protégée au titre des Monuments
Historiques depuis 1951 pouvez-vous nous
parler de l'architecture de cet édifice
on voit autour de nous essentiellement
des formes qui sont marquantes de
l'architecture gothique notamment le
fameux arc brisé les gouttes d'ogive
également brisé qui permettaiit de mieux
répartir le poids de l'édifice sur sur
les través et sur les piliers des
églises et donc de créer des ouvertures
plus importantes comme on voit ici au
niveau du cœur ce qui permet d'avoir
plus de lumière donc dans la partie la
plus sacré de l'édifice le cœur c'était
très avantageux au niveau de cette
architecture on voit également que on a
un enduit blanc très simple qui a été
revalorisé par la restauration récente
et qui est tout à fait typique d'une
architecture de village très simple de
de cette église et on voit que l'enduit
blanc de la restauration a permis de
mettre bien en valeur les croix pâtées
que vous vous avez sur les piliers de
l'église donc les croix rouges pâé qui
sont l'emblème de l'Ordre des Chevaliers
du Temple qui était également qui se
retrouve sur les armes des la famille
piedde fer seigneur de guillencour donc
le lien avec l'Église se fait comme ceci
donc l'ordre du Temple les Templiers
d'une manière plus générale ont été
assez présents sur la ville nouvelle oui
effectivement cette la présence de cette
croix ici qui vient probablement donc
des armes de la famille Fed de fer
seigneur de guillencour montre que
l'Ordre du Temple était très influent
dans la région et localement en
particulier on le voit d'ailleurs par un
vestige très important qui est la
commanderie templière de la ville Dieu à
hencour qui a elle aussi subi d'ailleurs
des restaurations récentes nous nous
sommes rendus à la Commanderie des
Templiers à hencour retour sur ce site
qui mêle tradition et modernité en
accueillant des expositions
contemporaines
à hencour les vieilles pierres de la
commanderie des Templiers ont des choses
à nous raconter une visite découverte
entre patrimoine et art contemporain
nous est proposée le premier dimanche de
chaque mois dans le cadre du la belle
ville d'arê d'histoire il y a la moitié
de la visite qui est vraiment sur
l'histoire et l'architecture des lieux
et puis dans le même temps on propose
aux gens de découvrir l'exposition
actuelle du site donc l'exposition d'art
contemporain puisque aujourd'hui c'est
le cœur du projet de la commanderie des
temp lié donc en ce moment c'est une
exposition de dessin ça change
régulièrement et et comme ça les gens
peuvent même revenir plusieurs fois avec
leurs amis et eux voir une exposition
différente à chaque fois sur les chemins
de Saint-Jacques de Compostelle ce lieu
emblématique fondé au 12e siècle par les
moines soldats de l'Ordre du Temple a
connu de multiples affectations utilisé
au départ pour l'accueil des pèlerins
puis convertie en exploitation agricole
la Commanderie est restaurée et ouverte
au public dans les années 70
une deuxième vague de restauration en
2008 et 2012 en fait aujourd'hui un
centre culturel et historique à vocation
polyvalente l'art contemporain est à
l'honneur cette année dans le bâtiment
des gardes qui accueille les expositions
temporaires l'originalité de la visite à
de voix offre ainsi au public une mise
en parallèle entre l'histoire de ce lieu
de patrimoine et l'art contemporain qui
y est exposé on avait jamais eu de
parcours historique sur la Commanderie
on a l'habitude de voir des sculptures
modernes ici des artistes des artistes
contemporains et ça nous choque pas de
le mélange du deux hein la chapelle
dernier témoin médiéval de la région et
les expositions sont à découvrir tous
les premiers dimanches du
mois nous sommes toujours à l'intérieur
de l'église Saint-Victor à guillancour
devant cette fresque découverte lors des
derniers travaux de restauration lors
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
peu plus les restaurations de 2011-22
ont mis au jour une fr qui daterait
vraisemblablement de la fin du 16e et du
début du du 17e siècle donc c'est
toujours quelque chose d'assez émouvant
quand on fait ce genre de découverte
quand on est restaurateur voilà ou même
animateur du patrimoine c'est très
excitant donc c'est quand même une belle
fresque au fusin donc la différence
entre la fresque et la peinture
murale c'est que la peinture murale les
pigments sont liés sur la fresque on
pose en fait les pigments etci le fusin
sur un enduit frais d'où le terme de
fresque qui vient de Fresco en italien
et en séchant il y a une réaction
chimique en fait fait qui forme une
couche transparente sur la les pigments
et qui protège la fresque donc c'est des
choses qui sont qui résistent assez bien
et par contre là on voit que l'artiste
de l'époque avait une certaine dextérité
puisque c'est très difficile de
reprendre le tracé puisque ça sèche très
vite donc là on voit qu'est-ce que
justement représente cette traise alors
on voit une jambe dans un étrier avec un
petit éperon un serpent un dragon
vraisemblablement avec une aile de ce
côté-là on voit une lance et la vent un
cheval donc on peut assez avec assez de
certitude dire que cette fresque
représente vraisemblablement
saint-georgge Terrassin de dragon qui
est un motif traditionnel de
l'iconographie chrétienne qu'on retrouve
dans les manuscrits et que plus tard des
peintres comme Raphaël ou Rubin se
reprendront qui a un motif très
symbolique de de la victoire du Bien
contre le Mal de la victoire que de la
foi terrassant le diable donc qu'on
retrouve aussi dans beaucoup de
peintures murales ou fresques donc là on
a vraiment àaire à une scène assez
classique qui a aidé beaucoup à
reconnaître le motif de de cette fraisee
pour ce qui est de la restauration quand
on découvre ce genre de chos aujourd'hui
au 20e siècle on fait plus comme au 19e
siècle à recréer les zones manquantes
pour ne pas que ça se voit on essaie
d'être le plus juste possible
historiquement et le plus vrai
c'est-à-dire de pas faire croire à un
dessin
complètement intact mais de laisser en
fait les lacunes de de nettoyer la
couche picturale de refixer les pigments
et ensuite de protéger pour montrer
vraiment l'état lacunaire qui est un
témoignage de l'histoire à cette date où
on l'a redécouverte et pas une peinture
qu'on est on recrée dans sa splendeur
qui du coup serait fausse de l'époque où
peuvent se renseigner les les curieux
qui voudrai davantage d'information si
vous voulez en savoir plus sur l'égise
de guencour vous pouvez venir nous voir
au musée de la ville nous notre rôle
c'est de valoriser le patrimoine
saquentinois dans son ensemble donc on a
un CRE de documentation on raconte
l'histoire du territoire et si vous
voulez en savoir plus en particulier sur
la fresque et sur la restauration le
service communal des archives de
guyencour et son archiviste Isabelle
Gourmelin a suivi le projet de
restauration et donc sûrement beaucoup
de secrets à retransmettre encore sur
cette fresque et puis sur les détails de
restauration de de l'égise en général
merci beaucoup lur pour votre éclairage
merci à
vous nous poursuivons notre découverte
des lieux historiques toujours à
guillancour et toujours accompagné de
l'orvallette merci alors nous nous
trouvons devant une ancienne batterie
militaire alors on a fait un saut dans
temp puisque c'est un édifice du 19e
siècle pouvez nous raconter un peu
l'origine de ce lieu après la défaite de
la France contre la Prusse en
1870 qui a été un réel choc puisque les
armées ennemies sont très rapidement
arrivées jusqu'à Paris on a identifié
qu'il y avait un problème de défense de
la région parisienne et même au-delà
donc on décide la mise en place d'un
système de fortification à l'échelle
nationale et plus particulièrement une
ceinture fortifiée autour de Paris de
Fort de batterie et de redoute dont fait
partie la batterie Bouvier construite en
1879 pour en fait permettre de boucher
la trouée qui existait encore entre les
forts de saint-ir et de Buc et qui
risquait de constituer donc un passage
possible pour les les troupes ennemis
ensuite cette batterie ne ne servira
finalement jamais de lieux de défense
proprement dit elle restera une base
arrière pour les troupes dont aussi son
nom de de redoute qu'on entend parfois
redoute du lieu ridoto où l'on se retire
en italien euh jusque donc la première
guerre mondiale où servira effectivement
de base arrière puis ensuite avec la
Première Guerre mondiale on s'aperçoit
que elle est obsolète ce lieu devient
obsolè par rapport à la guerre moderne
et et on décidera du coup de
l'abandonner en tant que que lieu
militaire proprement dit est-ce que ce
lieu a malgré tout connu une seconde vie
oui entre effectivement cette époque là
et et aujourd'hui le lieu a a connu bien
d'autres histoires donc en dans les
années 1930 le ministère de la Défense
loue ce lieu à l'entreprise Hispano
Suiza qui s'installe sur les lieux qui
est une entreprise de de d'industrie
militaire aéronautique et automobile et
qui va donc effectuer sur ce lieu des
fabrications de munitions des essais de
moteur notamment puis lors de
l'occupation allemande dans la au moment
de la 2uxième guerre mondiale une partie
des activités d'Hispano Suiza est
délocalisé et puis après la deuxième
guerre mondiale ne subsistera sur sur le
lieu que l'activité aéronautique et
notamment les fameuses turbine du
célèbre transibérien ont été construit
ici voilà et puis ensuite la crise
économque et puis l'arrivée de la ville
nouvelle vont provoquer le le départ
avec
l'urbanisation contemporaine de
l'entreprise hispanoiza qui quitte
définitivement ces lieux en 1993 alors
du coup le lieu est laissé là aussi à
l'abandon encore quelques temps
effectivement le lieu est laissé à
l'abandon quelques temps puisque c'est
seulement en
1999 que l'établissement public
d'aménagement de C an en Iville qui
aménage la ville nouvelle qui urbanise
canttins en iine va racheter au
ministère de la Défense le site de la de
la batterie de Bouvier pour ensuite le
le réhabiliter le restaurer et en faire
un lieu de vie contemporaine puisque ce
patrimoine ancien il ne peut pas rester
en tant que tel juste pour sa valeur
symbolique il doit aussi continuer à
vivre et donc se transformer pour
pouvoir accueir de nouvelles activités
donc ce lieu a connu différentes
périodes historique utilisé à des fins
différentes mais en terme de
d'architecture qu'est-ce qui a été
conservé ou peut-être modifié
effectivement lors de la réhabilitation
dans les années 2000 le cabinet
d'architecte contemporain a fait le
choix en fait de de détruire certaines
parties qui étaient les bâtiments
annexes qui avaient été construits en
fait au moment de l'occupation
industrielle du site Paris espanosuiza
pour mieux revaloriser et et réhabiliter
l'architecture militaire de départ en
fait pour vraiment redonner son identité
historique patrimoniale à ce lieu voilà
il y a également des d'autres ajouts qui
ont été faits d'architecture
contemporaine pour pouvoir permettre
l'exploitation de ce de ce lieu et donc
aujourd'hui on a un mariage de la pierre
de meelière et de l'architecture
militaire classique initiale et du
contemporain pour donner un lieu nouveau
et en même temps très symbolique
patrimonialement parlant donc en fait ce
lieu est véritablement un symbole d'une
revalorisation du patrimoine utilisé à
des fins plus contemporaines aujourd'hui
on qu'est-ce qu'on peut trouver
d'ailleurs dans cette cette fameuse
batterie déjà le le mot batterie
effectivement est complètement
symbolique puisque naturellement le donc
la le mot batterie de l'architecture
militaire qui désigne qui vient de la
batterie d'artillerie hein de des armes
voilà et qui qui a été du coup appelé
également batterie en écho à la musique
contemporaine donc ce nom est en
lui-même un un symbole du du passé
patrimonial du lieu et puis les studios
de répétition notamment sont situés dans
les anciennes cas mat qui au fond de la
cour sont les les petits bunkers he qui
abritaent soit des des stockages de
pièces d'artillerie soit qui habitait
des hommes c'est des endroits où on
vivait où on mangeait ensuite on a
conservé également la façade cette belle
façade
réhabilitée avec les joints refaits et
cetera avec le le nom de la batterie de
Bouvier et la date de 1879 inscrit
inscrit dessus et puis par contre on a
comblé les fossées les douves tout c'est
ce système défensif qui n'avait plus
lieu d'être évidemment
puisqueaujourd'hui c'est un lieu
convivial et accueillant c'est un lieu
où on peut venir écouter des concerts où
on peut venir répéter des studios de
danse ou des studios lieu de musique
donc un lieu d'enseignement aussi et
puis c'est aussi un lieu qui abrite un
restaurant aujourd'hui donc on peut
venir passer un moment agréable
justement dans la partie ancienne avec
une verrière contemporaine qui est venue
s'adjoindre pour accueillir les gens
dans ce dans ce café musical donc c'est
un lieu très sympathique où on peut
venir passer un moment de détente
agréable et du coup qui retrouve une
vraie vie merci levallette de nous avoir
accompagné tout au long de ce magazine
nous poursuivons notre voyage à la
découverte du château de la Madeleine à
Chevreuse c'est depuis ces escaliers
étroits du 13e purement militaire que
les mercenaires descendaient d'eau au
mur se mettant alors en danger de mort
lors des assauts en face dans la cour
centrale ce puit avec sa gargouille en
pierre calquaire armé d'une gouttière
ostentatoire purement décorative faisait
à l'origine 80 m de profondeur il n'en
accuse plus que 30 aujourd'hui
l'effondrement a fait son œuvre
désormais ses BIM recueille surtout les
portables des visiteurs
distraits à l'intérieur un escalier 14e
irrégulier à souhait mène au cave
indispensable au Moyen-Âge car la
population consomme alors entre 1 et 3
les de vin par jour pour soigner la
dysanerie mot particulièrement courant à
l'époque faute
d'hygiène le château de la Madeleine
regorge d'anecdotes et autres récits
passionnants situés sur les hauteurs de
chevreuses cette forteresse est est
intimement lié à l'histoire de France en
1306 Philippe Lebelle et l'impératrice
de Constantinople y séjournent en 1415
Jean sanspeur allié du roi d'Angleterre
livre bataille et laisse la ville en
ruine au 16e siècle les guerres de
religion font rage et le château déclaré
féon est finalement épargné par Henri
lui-même ici c'était au 16e siècle
c'était le bastion catholique
d'île-de-fance c'était le pouvoir
central de l'antipouvoir protestant il
fallait découant et symboliquement h
pouvait très bien le raser ce château
aujourd'hui visiter le château de la
Madeleine c'est simmerger dans 10 siècle
d'histoire le donjon la tour des gardes
sœur jumelles de la tour de la Bastille
et une croisée d'augive purement
décorative le bourgeois singe le noble
première période bling bling de
l'histoire sans oublier une vue
imprenable du haut des remparts depuis
lesquels les visiteurs peuvent
contempler le bourg de l'
le moyen-âge c'est Châteaufort les
chevaliers une période de l'histoire qui
en intéresse encore plus d'un certains
même s'amus à revivre grandeur nature
cette période de l'histoire nous nous
sommes rendus au médiéval de nfle le
château c'était en juin
dernier jant dame et dame oiseau
chevaliers et écuyers bienvenue au
médiéval de nafle le château ce weekend
le village a rrouvé ses origines
médiévales de jours de festivité
organisé par le Lyon club de nafle ont
transporté petits et grands à travers
les portes de
l'histoire le but final de l'opération
en dehors du plaisir de recevoir les
gens et de leur faire profiter d'une
belle fait c'est aussi de d'alimenter
les caisses œuvres sociales du lion club
de nfle Château ce qui nous permettra
dans les mois et les années qui viennent
bien sûr d'aider ceux qui ont tendance à
rester un peu sur le bord de la la route
d'aider ceux qui essayent de faire du
bien à gauche et à droite animation
pédagogique spectacle marché médiéval et
location de costume ont ainsi redonné
vie au Moyen-Âge offrant au visiteurs
une immersion totale nous ce qu'on
voulait voir effectivement c'était le le
tournoi là des chevaliers puis après on
a essayé le tir à l'arc sur le sanglier
les différentes armes que nous
présentent les le camping
d'cossé après avoir découvert le camp
viking et admiré le dracard de Rolon le
spectateur non initié ferru de
reconstitution historique a également pu
assister au tournoi international de jou
équestre une véritable compétition entre
chevalier s'affrontant pour le titre de
la lance d'argent le style français
c'est on est souvent bon cavalier enfin
je dirais qu'en général on a un bon
niveau équestre et
euh on a la réputation d'être assez dur
en lance quoi en lance sont assez
puissantes voilà on doit avoir confiance
en l'adversaire qui vient en face de
nous euh on peut se faire extrêmement
mal hein on charge avec une lance hein
donc il faut pas qu'il y ait d'animosité
il faut pas faut vraiment que on reste
dans le fairpl donc ça veut dire qu'il y
a le respect de son adversaire hein donc
le respect des autres et le fair playay
c'est des grandes qualités qui font
partie bah qui qui faisait partie du
moyen-âge et euh de ce que devait être
un chevalier hein forte admiration pour
les valeurs chrétiennes du Moyen-Âge
pour un respect de Dieu de la Parole du
Seigneur
euh et d'un certain mode de vie qui en
découlait violent
oket on le juge maintenant depuis notre
siècle c'est facile les mentalité a été
adaptée à une époque violente et je
pense que quand même le le respect de
ses valeurs proches du Seigneur faisait
que le monde fonctionnait correctement
l'intégralité des bénéfices de cet
événement servira à financer les œuvres
sociales soutenues par le lonce club de
nfle le
château ce magazine consacré à
l'histoire et au patrimoine du
département est à présent terminé merci
de nous avoir suivi sur TV fil je vous
souhaite un très bon été à
bientôt